mittlerweile kursiert ein video im netz
das zeigen soll wie es überhaupt auf
diesen sturm auf den reichstag gekommen
ist zu sehen ist eine frau auf der bühne
vor dem reichstag sie hetzt die
demonstranten auf behauptet die
polizeibeamten würden jetzt alle ihre
helme ablegen und sich auf die seite
demonstranten schlagen außerdem sei
donnell frankreich zu bewegen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
danach stimmt ca 400 chaoten den
reichstag und schwenken unter anderem
die sogenannte reichs flagge in schwarz
weiß rot wie sie die reichs bürger
verwenden nur eine handvoll polizisten
gelang es den wütenden mob vom
eindringen in das gebäude fern zu halten
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
verurteilte den sturm auf den reichstag
scharf reichs flaggen und rechtsextreme
pöbeleien vor dem deutschen bundestag
sind ein unerträglicher angriff auf das
herz unserer demokratie das werden wir
niemals hinnehmen sagt steinmeier
und in den vielen videos die es von
diesen sturm auf den reichstag gibt
fallen immer wieder drei polizisten auf
sie sind die helden vom berliner
reichstag wir sehen sie wie sich tapfer
vor unser parlament stellen um dieses
dann vor dem wütenden mob zu schützen
vor corona leugnern reichs bürgern und
neonazis sie wurden von dem ansturm so
überrascht dass einer von ihnen sein
einsatz helm nicht einmal auf hat
sondern nur mit einem funkgerät in der
hand unser parlament verteidigt die drei
setzten pfefferspray ein um die wütende
menschen zurückzuhalten einer der
polizisten ist einsatzleiter karsten
doneck der mit seinen kollegen sonst
hier in berlin am drogen brennpunkt am
kotti im einsatz ist
über diesen einsatz möchte ich jetzt
sprechen mit meinem kollegen erst bei
uns reporter und politik hätte matthias
lukaschewitsch was wissen wir über
diesen ansturm vor allem über den
einsatz den die polizisten dort am
samstag geleistet haben was wir wissen
was wir klar sagen können in dem moment
als die der wütende mob die treppe hoch
kam waren zu wenig eigentlich keine
polizisten keine polizisten
das ist ein debakel es kam dann sind
offenbar dann die gruppe von herrn
bonner sind dann zwei drei leute zwei
polizisten beamte sind dann zur treppe
hin gestürmt und haben versucht zu
sichern was zu sichern ist noch mit
bloßen händen wir sehen uns ja mit
schlagstöcken versuchen sie mit
lenkbewegungen die menge zurückzuhalten
die dort hoch steigt in letzter sekunde
konnte die tür zugemacht werden zum
bundestag
es sind verstörende bilder und man muss
klar sagen dass das einsatzkonzept dort
an der stelle überhaupt nicht aufgehen
also war der einsatz falsch geplant
werden komplett war
geplant war selbst wenn man nicht damit
gerechnet hat dass dort ein durchbruch
stattfindet hätte man das gebäude
schützen das sind man hätte einfach eine
polizeikette davor stellen müssen es
gibt nicht so viele gebäude im
regierungsviertel
die man schützen muss das sind das
bundeskanzleramt das ist der der
reichstag und dort war keine polizei
jetzt muss sich am vormittag in senator
geiste den fragen also rede und antwort
stehen hier in berlin im
abgeordnetenhaus was denkst du was für
konsequenzen dieser samstag für ihn
haben wird im moment hält sich das
politische berlin noch relativ zurück
mit mit rücktrittsforderungen oder mit
konsequenzen die innensenator kreise
ziehen könnte müsste vielleicht
fakt ist aber wenn ihr die fragen die
offenen fragen zum einsatzkonzept im
innenausschuss des berliner
abgeordnetenhauses nicht beantworten
können nicht ausreichend und nicht
plausibel
dann wird das entgegen